[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the reuben report
i am not dave rubin i am michael knowles
but we are
here because you know dave has been away
now
for an entire month he's been in bliss
he's been in paradise away from all the
misery
and we are going to spoil all of that
for them
this is the reuben report
welcome back knowles
i have literally no idea what's going on
in the world we have sat here for a few
minutes talked about life
yes but not news you did not reveal
anything no
i truly know nothing i
absolutely nothing i knew people don't
believe it but it's true when you asked
me
to host your coming back show yeah i
knew oh there'd be a lot of fun
we've seen it in years past ben has done
it glenn has done it oh you know
there's always some crazy news you have
no
idea this year you know they always say
that's the most important election in
our lifetimes
this is the craziest year of news in my
entire lifetime
and you thought things you thought
things were bad in july probably right
well everyone thought things were bad in
july i can tell you this so first off in
a weird way
even though obviously whatever you're
about to tell me about
yeah like you could almost tell me
anything at this point you could tell me
aliens invaded
tell me joe biden's head exploded you
could tell me coronavirus was a hoax you
could tell me half the country has it
you could tell me almost anything and i
could pretty much believe it
because that's how bananas the world has
become
but oddly getting off the grid this year
and this is the fourth time i've done
this august off the grid thing
in a weird way this was the easiest
because in years past i traveled
i went to the gym yeah i went to public
places to restaurants restaurants and in
those places they often have televisions
where they're showing the news or i was
in an airport
i was home this whole time we moved but
i was home so i had no people around me
anywhere and
in other years if i went to the store
people would come up to me like dave i
know you're off the grid but come on you
have your phone on you don't you like
like literally fine
give me that pocket keeping me honest
i'm not kidding i would do that i'd pull
my pockets i'd be like i got nothing
but now uh because i'm in a mask yeah
when i'm out
right nobody came up to me so i have had
almost no human communication even this
morning when i got here
just to say hi to the security guard i
was like whoa that's what it's like to
be with like a human because i've been
i've been with david basically on her
dog
that's pretty much it i have no freaking
clue what's going on i'm a little afraid
honestly i envy you i wish that i had
this kind of
month away from all the craziness before
we get into
before i just burst your list and your
piece
yes how was it how was it going away did
you miss it
were you itching for the twitter were
you i am excited to be
back and i'm excited to be sitting here
with you and this is going to be fun and
like
people are going to get the reactions in
real time and then i'll get right back
in the fight tomorrow
yeah but it was really really great um
first off the reason we're doing this
here at the daily wire is because i
moved and we
rebuilt the reuben report studio which
will debut tomorrow
uh separately i notice we've got your
graphics we've got new music
like my team was busting their butts one
of the things that that
was different this year is that in years
past when we've gone away and i just i'm
laying at the beach and i'm reading and
whatever is my phone is is literally
locked in a safe we couldn't do that
this year because i had like plumbers
and electricians and
people working on things and things like
that but also the way we're connected
actually really struck me this year more
than past because
like i have sonos music right in my
house like the sonos system
so like if i wanted to listen to music i
actually needed my phone
so i took out an old iphone and i it
wasn't connected
to the the cellular network right but it
just had my wi-fi to make sure i wasn't
going to get notified
like these weird things or to turn on
nest air conditioning you need your
phone
yeah that's true they have figured out
ways the security systems now go through
the phone
right right everything right cameras at
my house like everything
it all goes through this thing that
we're walking around with and even if
you want to get off it like just to not
know the news
like something that should be kind of
simple
that thing that matrix has uh so
locked in yeah it's crazy like there i
guess i could have busted out my old
cd player by a little my little boombox
next still to call your friends you're
right your walkman to listen
yeah but it was great it was i feel
truly i feel
relaxed i feel calmer i feel
a little more patient i also feel um
what that whatever you're going to tell
me and this is what i thought a lot
about over the last couple days
is that i think what i've realized is
the reason that this is important to do
is that for especially for guys like us
and in a weird way everyone's become
like us right like
meaning creatures of the news because
this has now taken over everything and
in the public too right everyone's in
the public if you have any kind of
social media account
you are a public facing person right so
while we do it
with fancier cameras and things like
that everyone is like in this
fight right yeah everyone's in this
thing and what i realized is
when you wake up every day and i try not
to have my phone in my room anyway
uh when i'm on the grid um when you wake
up and you're always in the fight and at
any given moment
somebody could say something horrible
about you or that this media thing
like that keeps you in this like it
sounds cliche almost but like it keeps
you like a
like a rat or a hamster on a wheel and
your brain is just going all the time
and it's just like this
endless thing that it's always like feed
me feed me feed me
and i feel like i really do have some
better perspective right now
like like whatever you're going to tell
me again world war iii could have
started
anti-fuck could have taken over the
white house i i have no clue
um what if i told you yes what if i said
to you
because you're so you're so happy right
now and you're totally at peace yeah
what if i told you everything calmed
down you know
there's no way the riots stopped and the
virus
cured and what if i would you believe
that not only would i not believe you i
thought a lot about that
yeah because every time someone would
come into my house and i had to announce
to plumbers and electricians and
everybody else
guys just don't because the news come
it's like why would a plumber come into
your house and tell you about the news
except we live in this bizarre world
where everyone talks about it all the
time right so i would literally someone
would come into my house i'd be like
listen i know it's gonna sound crazy
they don't know they don't know who i am
so you know so but like
don't tell me about the news okay but
that idea
that it could slow down or it could stop
there's just no way because every time i
told somebody what i was doing people
would be like the same thing everyone
said the same thing every time
oh it's much worse oh god it's worse now
you're not going to believe it when you
get back what happened this time
wait you don't know about that and then
i'd have to stop everyone they couldn't
stop them so i don't know anything about
the news but you know you must know
about that or
i was no no no um and then so so the
idea that it could stop
the idea that the machine could somehow
reverse
like that's why i think what we all want
yeah is we all sort of like even if you
think about it this way
february or so when the lockdowns began
i guess that was maybe the beginning of
march yeah that's not that long ago
right like it's like six months was it
15 days ago
he was told 15 days to slow the spread
was it no remember remember slow the
spread flatten the i assume we flatten
the
tell me we must have flattened the curve
the curve can we get the curve on call
here so we can
i think it's flattened i think it's but
like that the world is now changing so
fast that it's
that february now seems like the good
old days yeah
and i think what we all want and what we
all need
is some people and i'm really going to
try to do this going forward
i think i've tried to do it anyway i'm
going to try to be one of the people
that like
slowed down the machine from just
crushing everybody all the time
because we can start and i
have no doubt that almost everything
you're going to tell me is bad that
there won't have been like for example
i was thinking um all right well the
conventions happened i assume the
conventions happen
they did they did happen i'll spoil that
okay we'll get into the convention so
the conventions happen but i was
thinking like is there any chance like a
democrat
got up in the convention and said
identity politics is bad or rule of law
is good or
or the constitution is good or america
is kind of decent
like is there any chance that happened
i'm sure not
and i'll just say one other thing and
then okay all right here
uh so i had no no news no nothing but
one thing
one little thing happened which is one
night we were watching netflix
and we uh x out of netflix like went
back into apple tv
and something happened for it was two
seconds
yeah we somehow got on to the i guess it
was the democratic national
uh the convention and it all i heard
this is exactly what i heard was bernie
sanders
he i saw his giant head after not seeing
anything for 20 days
and he goes joe biden will fix our
crumbling
infrastructure and then and then we we
quickly shut the tv off that's the only
thing i heard but like
that like stupidity the level of yes joe
biden is going to fix our nurture
crumbling finally yeah he's only been in
government 50 years
when they built the infrastructure now
they're going to have to do it again but
i have no idea there could have been an
earthquake there could
anything could have happened well trump
could have shaved his head i have no
idea i want to start off with the most
important news yes then we'll get down
we'll do it in in uh
descending order yes descending of so
level of importance i'm going to start
with the most important stuff okay uh
wnba
canceled three games last wednesday
that night
wait are they playing in front of people
wait are they still a league is that a
league is that are we allowed to say
that now no
they cancel the three games for racial
justice
so if you want to watch your atlantic
dream or your
washington mystics play the game you
can't do it for racial justice wasn't
just them
the nba they're the one that people
actually watch cancelled games
why for racial justice wait you are
messing with me
i am not messing with you they canceled
games not because of covid but because
in in protest of racial and you don't
even know you don't even
i mean you're probably still thinking
george floyd or whatever no there have
been like seven since then there have
been so many
totally contrived incidents since then
yeah well just on the basketball front
so one of the things that i do
uh is when i'm doing cardio and i did
cardio i did about an hour of cardio
every day for the last month that's how
i pretty much start my mornings i have
some coffee i jump on the
elliptical machine and i watch old nba
games i watch 1990s you know jordan peak
years
nba games and there's a crowd
and people are screaming and it's all
people
and i said right before i went off the
grid because i watched like a few
minutes of one of these games in the
dome or whatever they call it you know
their place where there's no people and
you're watching millionaires yell at
referees and it all feels very
dystopian and evil it's like why would
anyone want to pay these people at this
point why would you want to give your
hard-earned money
to these they won't even play basketball
for a living yeah like
what what are they boy like they're the
the millionaire players
are boycotting the league with in the
league is pro
blm or whatever but they're and they're
very pro china
wait did something new happen that that
the nba players let's put the wnba as
well we'll put the w
for now yeah forever we can put that
aside so something new happened that
triggered so i will i will spoil it for
you the riots are still going that's
what we're doing that's what we're doing
the riots are still going on okay the
riots
have been going on this whole time there
was
there have been so many new attacks but
i'll give you the one that everyone's
talking about now
is blms come out uh there there's
antifa in the streets uh people are very
upset about this killing of a man named
jacob blake and i'll walk you through
the killing of jacob blake okay
jacob blake is a guy who had a warrant
out for his arrest he had a warrant out
for
sexual assault domestic violence
he obviously this woman called the cops
on him she said that he comes and
beats her up every time he gets really
drunk so the cops are out there
they pull their guns out and he is
resisting arrest
they try to tase him it doesn't doesn't
matter where is this
this is in kenosha wisconsin okay so
this guy
you know kenosha that thriving
metropolis so
but kenosha wisconsin keep in mind a
swing state
this guy's walking then he's he's
evading a rest he's got the
guns drawn on him he walks up to his car
opens the car door the car is full of
kids
reaches into the car where we all knew
he had a weapon stash but you weren't
allowed to say that
until finally it was confirmed and then
at that point after the police have been
yelling at this guy to
they shoot him and he's still alive by
the way he's not dead i think he's
paralyzed he's obviously very
his kids in the car it is i guess i
suppose that's a bit unclear
okay but you've got these so part of it
in other words it's just another one of
these stories
it's another one the media now frames it
as this is racism this is
yeah yeah you know one of the things
that i was thinking about a lot this
month
and i think when you get away from it
you can kind of see it a little clearer
is that uh i know guys like us do
complain about the media a lot and i
know that more and more people are
waking up to it but it really is an
evil machine yeah it really is an evil
machine that that
people are making money on pushing
narratives sounds like this like you
probably don't have to tell me that much
more to give me a clearer picture
you get that but now i'm getting so now
people are in the streets of kenosha
they burn the city down and but this is
where it gets even worse this is what
you're talking about
with the the kind of media just as the
puppet masters of everything you're
always on this wheel
so they're pouring out into the streets
blm antifa right
and then this one kid i guess he's a
conservative kid goes
to uh clean up the streets so he's there
there's a famous picture of him now
clearing the graffiti off of
conservatives always clean enough but he
came armed because he said look they're
riders in the streets
we have it on video that these blm and
antifa guys
are attacking this kid kicking him in
the head going after him
takes his gun shoots three of them
shoots three now
these three guys who are now being
hailed as heroes as saints
uh one of them was a serial domestic
abuser the other was a convicted child
molester one guy was chasing him with a
gun
so we're not we're not these weren't
social workers here they were right
right
but the media narrative is now they're
somehow the good guys and the media
narrative is that
they're the good guys that this kid is a
white supremacist based on absolutely
nothing
and the biggest change that's happened
since
you've been away is the media initially
and the left and the universities and
the elected officials
said there is no violence there are no
riots
these are peaceful mostly well that's
what they were telling us about portland
it was always peaceful
yeah in dc and all over the country
minneapolis yeah mostly peaceful
protests yeah
now they're saying that there is
violence
and it's being caused by white
supremacists
it's all they have left that's what i'm
saying when you step away from it
it's so obvious it's like nauseating
yeah all they've got left
is that the rest of us are white
supremacists yeah and we're not
and that isn't to say that there aren't
some white supremacists there are but
i'm going to go out
on a limb here knowles after being off
the grid for a month and guess that this
kid who was cleaning up is probably
not awake not a white sword you know
there's no i'm going to guess he wasn't
looking to shoot people that morning it
sort of sounds like that mccloskey story
yeah which was the the story
with the two people defending their
house in missouri yeah uh right before i
went off the grid
which was it's not everyone's trying to
frame it that they are bad guys and all
this stuff and it's like
they weren't waking up that morning like
let's bust out the guns
they didn't go to someone else's house
they were at their house
so god so the president to his great
credit comes out
and says the kid was acting in
self-defense he went now could you
imagine any other politician of either
party
actually going out on a political limb
and saying like ah rioter is bad
uh writers attacking people bad
self-defense
totally justified so trump goes out
there and says this
but this is the way it's being framed
and you see do you see the contradiction
there
that the media are trying to work out
totally peaceful no violence at all
all the violence has been caused by
white supremacists i thought there was
no violence what do you mean all the
violence is
and if you look down obviously there how
many white supremacists are there in the
country like seven or something how many
times can they pull the same trick
before we all wake up
and that is what i will tell you you
know one of the things that i actually
did get to do
is i'm sure like you i get a lot of
emails that are nice and people say nice
things about me or read your book or
whatever
but i get a lot of handwritten letters
and i usually don't have a lot of time
to be reading them but i did read a lot
of handwritten letters
that people sent me and almost every
time people
include the phrase wake up like i've
woke up it has something to do with some
of the things that you've talked about
or people
and it's like this type of stuff it's
like of course and it's like i'm sure
you're gonna tell me another city
something happened
yes yeah i mean so the riots are going
so nothing got
tempered down no one no it it only got
ratcheted up you know it only got worse
yeah
and you do realize that this is
hilarious that you didn't start with the
pandemic
no that's right the pandemic is like
story numbers is that oh that's not even
are we doing because like although
they're i got to tell you okay all right
yeah i wouldn't know by the way if
there's it you know
really anything you could tell me it was
over you could tell me it was a hoax you
could tell me 90
of us have it you could tell me half the
civilizations anything would would sort
of work out into oh that's possible
because
when you're not paying attention to the
news and then you we live in socal it's
sunny and 90 degrees every day everyone
here looks great
is healthy everything else and every
store if i went to the supermarket or
anywhere else
it like it sort of feels crazy i'm not
saying it's a hoax
i'm not but like it feels kind of crazy
to see healthy people wearing masks
all young healthy people where we know
it's not killing young healthy people
and yet
if you even say that i know i'm going to
get a lot of hate okay so then
i want i want to know what you what your
hunch is do you think
that the virus you know and people's
health and everything has it gotten
better since you've been away or has it
gotten worse you know are we
finally reopening are we locking down
again well i
so i can tell you from my l.a experience
i honestly don't know if restaurants are
open
right now or not i know i can go to the
supermarket and i went to cbs the other
day
and a guy yelled at me because i was
walking into the store without my mask i
did put it on as i was entering like i
was entering an airlock and i got
you know um so i would guess
that it all is worse i i would guess
that the
the the vision of it that we all hear
or c is worse because that's what the
media has to run with at least through
the election i don't know if it's
like i'm guessing you're not going to
read me numbers right now that show me
it's much worse or suddenly
lots of young people are dying or
something like that none of that in fact
it's so much better
in california yeah hospitalizations are
dropping deaths are dropping same thing
is true in orange county so this is good
san diego yeah it's good right good
that's all good great
so what's the plan to reopen no plan
there's no plan well
here is the plan we will nearly reopen
according to governor nussolini we will
nearly rio that guy's still around
he is somehow still around will nearly
reopen when
there is a lower than two percent test
positivity rate not contagious not
hospitalizations not deaths
that people that less than two percent
of the tests are coming back positive
so never so never right this is what i'm
talking about about the rat race and
what they get you to do
yeah you can find videos i'm sure you
have similar ones too you can find
videos of me saying two weeks into this
thing
that when they say flatten the curve
that i guarantee you once we flatten the
curve
that they will pick some other arbitrary
thing down the road that's true and i
remember i remember
when when newsome our governor here in
california when he said
okay we're going to lock down until
august 1st i remember saying
on on air people can find the videotape
i remember saying well
there's no reason to think they'll open
up then yeah and now they'll just come
up with some other arbitrary thing and
some other arbitrary thing
and we all keep playing along we all
keep playing along and again that's not
to say it's a hoax it's it's to say
there's something wrong with the
information system
or something like that like i've got two
two data points for you that just came
out actually one
adapted by the new york times still
illegal we're not allowed to only when
it
only when it goes along with the
left-wing narrative yeah so out of the
new york times
90 of uh people who test positive
uh are no longer contagious so ninety
percent so we've been told the whole
time
that even if you seem totally healthy
you could be a asymptomatic spreader
and this is gonna kill granny so you
gotta lock yourself in your home now
we're finding out actually even 90 of
people who test positive
are really not that contagious and then
this number is pretty crazy
from the cdc this number by the way even
if you logged on to twitter today you
wouldn't have seen it
because twitter banned it even using
data from the seats so twitter's still
abandoning reality oh
twitter's got it that was a big thing
right for those few days right before i
left the grid they were banning
it has only gone up the the percentage
of covid deaths
that were exclusively caused by covid
not by other comorbidities
you know not by others cancer whatever
six percent six percent of people who
died of covid
died specifically of covid which brings
the number from around 180
000 down to about 11 000 who died
specifically
from kovid you're not allowed to say
that on twitter
because people get it yet i know that
people get it they don't but people do
get it right like
the wake up that i just referenced like
it is happening at some level right and
you just can't see it
or sort of the mainstream tear won't let
you see it yes but the average person is
just going this is just too
obvious now it's too ridiculous we can
see the guy behind the curtain like what
are you guys doing well
you see that a little bit in the
reactions to the party conventions
yeah oh the party convention the party
conventions happened they both biden
biden's
alive biden uh technically i don't i
mean that's at least what they're saying
yeah so biden is still a nominee he is
my nominee yeah i'm still
i'm still you don't no do you have any
guesses who the vice president
okay so a day or two before i went off
the grid politico
leaked out that it was going to be
kamala harris and i sort of felt that
was like a little too obvious even
though he said it had to be a woman
and we know he said it has to be black
did he in fact say it
a woman of color oh so it could have
been elizabeth warren could have
obviously yeah
exactly about a week later and now that
now i have
was off the grid already i was uh in the
fruit section i was buying a melon
actually
i do enjoy a little watermelon in the in
the summer months it gets hot here
and uh and there was a woman like like
screaming
in joy uh about kamal harris so i
suspect
that it is kamala harris i'm guessing
it's kamala harris the way you're
nodding at me sort of
it is kamala harris she is the worst she
is the worst she is the worst i mean she
is the worst do you think she is the
worst do you think would have helped him
or hurt him in the polls
do i think that kamala would help him or
hurt him
well it can't really well first off the
polls at this point it's like who knows
what the polls mean it can't really help
because the democrats hated her nobody
voted for her nobody likes her
and and the the crazy lefties that are
running the show right now the anti-fa
bernie coalition of marxist lunatics
they all hate kamala harris because they
think she's like a corporatist
sellout but she ugh that's so gross
it's so gross and it did you know look
she's the worst she's the worst kind of
authoritarian
yeah you remember that moment at one of
the debates when she was still in it
when the question was asked to uh biden
about would you use an executive action
to ban
assault weapons or do something on guns
yeah and biden said
people can find this biden said oh it
would have to be constitutional
and kamala harris looks at him laughing
and she says joe
can't we just say yes we can
and it's like wait a minute you think
that you can use the power of the
executive branch to supersede the power
of the legislative branch on something
that's enshrined in the comments
yeah like she's the worst oh funny you
mentioned that
witchy cackle because you'll remember
this is the big problem when biden picks
her
uh she launched the most vicious attack
against biden
that has yet been launched this cycle
she she called him a vicious racist
at those early debates and said he was a
segregationist or whatever right oh
right
remember that the bus bus so
she goes on the colbert show and colbert
to his credit pushes a recess uh
uh senator harris what happened to joe
biden being a terrible racist
and she she puts on the cackle she goes
it was a debate and so he says right it
was a debate but
but you know are you saying you were
lying then or it's not because
hahaha it was a debate it was a debate
it's called a debate it was a debate she
must have repeated the word
that's how evil these people are that
that's what i'm talking about
yeah it's all becoming too obvious to
ever yes
yeah the the nonsense she never believed
he was a racist no one in their right
mind believes joe biden is a racist
but then you throw it out there and it
and and for anyone that's on the fence
about politics that's that's watching
this happen it's like
when you see them do it against their
own and it's a lie does it make you
wonder when they call everybody else
maybe it's a lie too
right but this stuff for some reason it
just sticks to conservatives more
than it does their own but wait so tell
me about that so so the polls are
they pick comma and you know you pick a
vice presidential candidate your polls
are supposed to go up that's the point
of picking a vice presidential balance
is the ticket maybe you win a state but
it's got to help you
the poll numbers went down so even
democrats were deeply dismayed by that
because who
who likes her who likes her she was one
of the first people out
in the primary nobody wanted this woman
to be the pick
and so this ties entity politics ruins
everything it touches period
including your own base of support yeah
right it's like even the democrats kind
of made this faustian bargain with like
okay we'll do this identity politics
thing
which is obviously evil and contrary to
logic and yeah but at least we'll get
more support
maybe for a little while but you go in
so first is the dnc yeah and the rnc
followed oh okay okay dnc
worst produced thing i've ever seen yeah
you would think democrats own hollywood
they wait and was it live or not
it was some of it was live
so live meaning they had there were
people oh no no no
all of it was it was a zoom call it was
the only question is were they was it
actually going out live
or was it did biden get out of the
basement or did he literally do it from
the basement
so he did he actually did somewhat well
in his
acceptance speech he slurred some words
but that's par for the course yeah uh
but he was barely in it he was barely a
part of this thing it was all this weird
zoom call stuff i actually want to do
two truths and a lie with you right now
just before we get into the dnc
okay okay so you tell me which one of
these
is the lie okay the dnc
removed the phrase under god from the
pledge of allegiance
ugh that feels true to me because
they've been trying to do this for a
long time
okay they booed god remember it was at
2012. yeah
okay so that feels true that feels true
hillary clinton urged americans to
respect the results of the election
no that doesn't feel true to me it
doesn't they they want even if it's
biden even if they think biden's going
to win
they they're setting it up knowing that
biden's brain is going to explode or
something but she doesn't want people
they haven't done it for four years yeah
these last four years so that that does
i guess
well like no i mean i suppose i could
envision a situation where she's
tipping to the people you know if our
guy wins let's make sure he accepts it
right i guess it's sort of pole
dependent right it's like it binds way
up in the polls and don't forget
when you went off the grid biden was way
up in the polls we can maybe get into
that a little bit too okay
one of my neighbors uh in the new house
does have a joe biden uh
you know a little placard in front of
his house it's bite in sunglasses
and it's got the american flag in each
eye is there anything more contrived
than the stupid biden
aviator thing i wear aviators he's
ruined he's ruined aviators it's so lame
yeah third one trump brought peace to
the middle east
i like the way you play this game
knowles that seems more legit to me
than the democrats respecting the
election if trump wins
um but i'm going to go on the assumption
that that is false
okay um so so then you got so that
you've got these three
dnc removes under god hillary clinton
says respect the election trump brings
peace to the middle east
yeah so which is the lie
well trump didn't bring peace to the
middle east
although you know i've been away for a
while knowles we live in a strange time
there's peace in the middle east there's
sort of peace in the middle east
and trump sort of peace so there is an
historic deal
that was just signed normalizing
relations between israel
and the united arab emirates this is the
first time that israel
has normalized relations with an arab
country in at least two decades
26 years or something like this is
actually world historic news wow
and of course it's being blocked out of
the mainstream media even if you had
been in the news you probably wouldn't
have seen this
during the week because it's the
mainstream media is not talking about it
so trump actually does this he gets
absolutely no credit for it of course
the under god thing yeah dnc did remove
it at the start of the
muslim caucus and the lgbt caucus so it
wasn't at the start of
mentioning god but at those two could
you imagine
that's really twisted but that's not
surprising it seems to me
the the lgbt caucus i guess there's no
direct
it's not like that's a religious group
right it's not religious so all right
let's just put that one aside for a
second but the muslim caucus
that doesn't make a lot of money they
believe in god i think they do
so they do because obviously the dnc is
now just totally secular
totally atheistic and you were right
hillary clinton
of course i love i love that it is more
believable
that trump brings peace to the middle
east than that hillary clinton says
respect the election
and not only is it believable it's true
hillary clinton went out there and said
joe biden should not concede this
election
under any circumstances not just he
shouldn't concede it's close it'll be a
little
under any circumstances it's it's so
obvious to me that the democrats invited
this evil cancerous ideology into the
house
they invited it in and now it has
ransacked the entire place
it's pulling the copper wiring from the
walls on the way out
the entire thing is collapsing and there
is so
really this is true like i don't mean
this to be hyperbolic there's almost
nothing you could have said to me yeah
that happened at the dnc thing short of
the
short of biden burning the american flag
like right up there like you hey let's
just do it everybody um
that i wouldn't have believed because i
don't i hope maybe more people are
realizing how
how evil and corrupt and anti-american
and everything else this thing has
become
yeah and i look forward to criticizing
the republicans in just a moment when
you tell me a little bit about what
happened there but like
this there's nothing we've discussed
this a million times in the last year
there is nothing the liberals can do the
good decent liberals who
are scattered throughout the galaxy and
there's very few of them left there's
nothing they can do to stop this thing
if you think
if you think that joe biden is the thing
that's going to stop
antifa and this and the
rot that is aoc and the rest of them
and i just i say it all the time but i
can't wait till it takes out bernie
that that when it comes around for
bernie and they're dancing
as they destroy him which they will
right he's like
he's a conservative corrupt white
supremacy and he backed joe biden after
backing hillary clinton and he was never
a true revolutionary
they'll get him he you know whatever um
but man the god thing i mean that is
you know what it reminds me of that you
remember that quote from marianne
williamson remember marianne and the
crystals the dark
psychic forces well remember when she
said the thing about
um when she got caught off mike or she
got on a hot mic
after she was on some show where she
said you know i understand she's like
i've never gotten the hate from the
right that i get from the left which is
her own side
and she goes i understand why the
conservatives call them godless
and it's like it does make sense they
don't believe in anything other than
power
yeah yeah you know that that doesn't
mean every single one of them i don't
think they're all awful people but biden
who i think is probably a decent man you
know what i mean he doesn't know what he
believes anymore and now
the party ugh it's gross i actually feel
gross it was
i felt great about it yes no it's well
it's only gonna get worse i mean we've
barely
really gotten into it yeah the thing
about the dnc was it was about
nothing it was truly about nothing it
was about
you know they had 10 million different
identity groups 5 million of which were
created in the last 6 months
and it was all about orange man bad and
there really was no
at any point there was no specific
argument for why
we need to vote for joe biden one thing
that was curious about it though
you know they take god out of a few of
these caucus meetings they've got this
kind of anti-american
sentiment they say they're going to
destroy capitalism in the youth caucus
they
you know because this was all a big zoom
meeting all the republicans infiltrated
it and so you actually got these kind of
secret meeting videos it was one of the
positives of coronavirus of the
lockdowns rather
but the the one thing is they tried to
seem
patriotic now isn't that oh they they
actually tried it right yeah but they
can't do it but they can't do it it was
not believable andy cuomo got out there
and he said
we're america tough we're gonna be with
a great country we're going to be
america tough
18 months ago andrew cuomo said we're
not going to make america great again
america was never that great
so what happened yeah why are they
trying to do it
as you were watching it as someone
that's not on that side you're obviously
not a democrat
but i know you're a pretty fair guy like
were you trying to pilfer out anything
sensible because i real you know even
though i'm obviously not a democrat i
don't consider
you know i'm registered here as a
democrat because i wanted to vote
against sanders
yeah which is it's all so stupid but um
i do try to look at both things
objectively and pill for some kind of
like can i get something honest like can
this all be was there anything there
no like did biden offer anything there's
nothing left no the the thing he offered
is he said
the theme of his campaign is we're going
to restore the soul of the nation and
and donald trump called neo-nazis very
fine people at charlottesville that's
not true which is
not true it's obviously he says in the
next paragraph he says
i'm not talking about the neo-nazis and
white supremacists who should be
condemned totally yeah it doesn't matter
he said that in the previous before he
said the thing about these good people
on both sides he said that first
actually and he's that's the part that
always gets cut yeah because they never
play them together yeah
but that's the lie that the campaign was
founded on and so when you listen to
biden you think
wow he's making a really good argument
about a fantasy
about a thing that didn't happen but a
thing that didn't happen and so
how can he arrive at this conclusion
based on a false premise
so that was that was the dnc all vague
or whatever
the reason that the democrats are still
pushing
all of these race riots and stoking all
these race riots
because the rnc did a great job of
black and minority outreach this was the
you know it's so funny
in a way it was like almost pandering
you thought oh my gosh it's like every
black republican in the world is coming
and speaking at this thing
but they wanted to make the point the
democrats are calling us racist we are
manifestly not racist
the rnc i got to tell you i think it's
because of trump so wait was it in
florida i'm forgetting where the rnc was
all over there oh so it wasn't that
wasn't physical either
oh it was all except they made there was
a difference here
the republican convention came afterward
and they learned from the democrats
the problem with the democrat convention
it was so it was so
dull there was no surprises right the
republican convention
was people giving live speeches to
nobody and sometimes that was kind of
hilarious you know
kim guilfoyle was a very energetic you
know she kind of got memed afterward
um but you know people were passionate
and they were giving these live speeches
warts and all
there were some really amazing
highlights of it and and the difference
was that the democratic convention was
all vague it was all trump's
meaning and he's bad the republican
convention put up the victims
of these riots do you remember david
dorn the black
uh former police officer who was killed
in the riots yeah
his widow gave an unbelievable speech it
just
totally uh the parents of uh kayla
mueller who was abducted by
and killed by isis they gave a speech
specific about obama's policies
obama biden's policies uh it was that
specificity that really
really got you and then trump's speech
which went on for 70 minutes
was all specifics it was i did this i
did that i did this we're going to do
this
we're going to do that after
after the convention his approval among
black voters right we're talking about
all this racial division in the rockets
how much do you think it changed do you
think it went up or down i've kind of
given it away already
uh i think knowles i've been out of the
game for a little bit but you did leave
me there
um you know i tweeted about a year ago
that that trump's gonna get 30 percent
of the black vote
that's an insane no one in their right
mind would say that but
i put these things out there on twitter
that's what i do as a professional
um i'm going to guess that his support
will tell me what the support was going
on before it was going in and this is
this is mid-august these are very recent
numbers support was 15
15 approval yeah i'm guessing it could
it could be around 30
it hit it hit 24. already and by the way
that's only factoring in the first two
days that's not even factoring in
the last day of yeah it was just an
amazing surge because you got to
remember you say oh 24 that's not that
big
that's a 60 jump right if you go up that
many points over
over 15 if you go up nine points that's
a 60 jump well you know what it is you
can't
[ __ ] people forever yeah because
eventually
the masses wake up like the bullshitters
aren't that good at [ __ ] i think
that that's starting
to to become what what is real so it's
like if you're
if your whole narrative is america is
evil it was founded on racism
1619 project systemic racism
everything's evil we're an oppressive
state the patriarch
all of these things yeah well then you'd
go all right if
all of those horrible things are true
yeah i guess
they had something to do with the time
before trump you know what i mean you
can't suddenly blame it all on trump
so in a weird way their their own logic
or their own um
their own nonsense the nonsense that
they were peddling about how evil we all
are and how evil
the system that has freed more people
than any other country ever
the more they've peddled that nonsense
in a way it actually is telling you that
trump isn't
the horrible evil thing yeah because
it's like oh i guess
i guess obama was pretty evil he was
part of it and i guess biden was part of
it and that
nancy pelosi you haven't told me
anything about pelosi's pelosi she's
she's still ticking as far as i can tell
she's still still eating her ice cream
yeah but but you know what i'm saying
like if there if your whole
story is how horrible america is which i
suspect and has always been
which is what i suspect most of the dnc
what the convention was yeah
well in many ways you're actually saying
okay well then trump's not to blame
for anything right he's just a new guy
you may not like him
but he's a new guy who by the way at his
last uh
state of the union was talking about
all-time low black unemployment
and the congressional black caucus sat
there like this furious
i thought that was a good thing but what
do i know no that's that's right if
there is
systemic oppression if the system is
rotten then it it's not
this guy he's only been doing it for
three years well you know speaking of
these specific
yeah i do want to get into a little a
little kind of political celeb news you
got to be in on the gossip a little bit
of paper yeah yeah
what's going on so who got destroyed
someone must have been destroyed
people got this people okay people got
destroyed i want you to tell me which
one of these is
not true oh god okay yeah i'll just give
you
i give you four okay and one
is not true one is not true
okay okay
jerry falwell has resigned because
he was found out to be in a cuckold
voyeur
throuple with the pool boy
that's the first one kellyanne conway
has resigned from her post at the white
house
candace owens is pregnant
jake paul's house was not raided by the
fbi
which one of those you're asking me i
got a double negative
all right so jake paul's house was not
graded yes
i feel like his house being rated is
probably true i don't really know who he
is
yeah he's hitting the nuts or something
on youtube i'm not totally sure what he
does
yeah um but okay so that that he was not
raided
i feel like maybe he was raided candace
i'm good friends with candace but i
haven't spoke with her in a month but
i'm gonna guess
she could be pregnant so i'll take
candace as pregnant uh the jerry fall
cuckold thing is i think that's a little
beyond your imagination
so i'm going to say that that's true
you're going to say that the president
of a major because i want to be very
clear i love liberty university yeah i
love you
i've met jerry nice guy from our
interactions yeah but that seems
somewhat possible i suppose because i
don't picture you in
coming up with that story because you
don't know what's going on you don't
know
we're good wholesome guys so okay so
that so falwell and candace and what was
the other one
kellyanne conway is leaving the white
house that just seems like
to nothing for you to bring it up in
this so i'll accept that one is true
okay so i guess jake paul
not being raided yes those are all i
mean you flip the not obviously yeah
all of those stories are true all of
those jake paul's house was raided by
the fbi
so that that flipped okay let's just put
that one aside yeah okay forget that one
kellyanne conway stepped down okay
or she just stepped down it's a bit of a
scandal it's not a scandal it's nothing
she did it's that
her daughter made all of these social
media posts oh yeah i remember
anticipated right
and so uh kellyanne conway and
uh her husband george conway are
stepping back down from their jobs
kellyanne obviously the white house
george conway from the lincoln project
if you're oh
he's been called out good job yeah those
great people
so she is stepping down it's too bad
it's it's a family issue
i think it obviously it's been
heightened by the media scrutiny and
just how awful they've been to that
family
but that's pretty normal you know the
fall will thing i almost didn't want to
bring it up yeah can you can you i
didn't say
so one more time i just want to fully
understand it's so br i hate
i hate that it's a news story i actually
feel very bad for jerry falwell here
yeah
i but this is a story his wife
slept with the pool boy okay there's
another allegation now from a liberty
student
that his wife propositioned this liberty
student and they got a little frisky
okay there is now an accusation from the
pool boy
that jerry falwell watched
now that we don't know apparently this
pool boy was extorting them there had
been kind of rumblings of this for for a
little while
so jerry falwell now has formally
resigned from liberty university
my reaction is just personally having
been to liberty university
and spoke there at convocation i mean it
was an absolutely incredible
moment and i i don't think that that
just hearing you tell me that
doesn't change any of the reality of
what i saw there with the students and
with the staff and the dean and and
everything else um
you know are people into weird stuff and
like
are is the way the media operates to now
try to destroy
all of us for anything they can get any
of us on and our and
all of us have things that we're not
proud of or a past or a life
before fixing ourselves or any of those
things myself included of course we all
have
things um none of my things involve the
pool boy but you know what i mean like
like that that i mean that it all just
feels gross it doesn't feel
this is the thing yeah like it's like
you know what hopefully he can work it
out with his wife and he can
make amends with whoever he has to make
amends with and yeah yeah
i know it's it's this thing where i'm
sure the media and the lefties they've
been so nice they expected their privacy
and they've said all
forgiveness they're before the grace of
god go i
you know of course yeah not quite they
had a field day they were so
so happy and it's so funny because it
occurred to me
the media are the ones the left are the
ones who say do whatever you want
you can you know it's empowering yeah
there's a there's a very popular song
that you missed we'll get into it in a
little bit is the macarena back
it's uh it's a little racier than the
macarena oh god
but they tell you everything's all good
be sexually liberated have sex with a
zillion people do whatever
until jerry falwell does it and then
what did they say you're a hypocrite
because he sinned is it hypocritical
when christians sin
i don't think so yeah right christians
say okay we sin yeah that's
that's why we need forgiveness and
everything so it's just been it's been a
sort of awful story
i'm kind of glad he's going into the
wilderness for a little bit and
hopefully they lay off him
you know what's interesting is um there
were two i'm going to blank on at least
one of the guys names but there were two
stories
about democratic the donor who was the
guy buck edward oh yeah and byron west
hollywood who was giving homeless black
guys meth and having sex with him he's
been in pictures with hillary and
whatever the media completely ignored
that one i'm not i'm not
all right i think they overdosed someone
died
so that but that story got totally
buried because he's on you know he's on
the right side right
um and then there was a story of the guy
that la andrew gilliam is that his name
the guy
andrew gillum who lost uh he was almost
going to be governor of florida
yeah it was that yeah he got caught
doing meth and having sex with a bunch
of guys and whatever i
i don't begrudge him i i don't begrudge
him doing anything you could
you know i'm not i'm not for legalizing
meth but i don't begrudge people for
doing stuff and i don't begrudge people
for having consensual relations
but like again it's to your point of if
that was a republican or if that was a
christian
then we know these things get blown up
but they're democrats so somehow they
can
get away with everything while also
making sure that everyone else is
destroyed for it that
that right there is the thing that we
have to get past as a nation
all the good people have to get
past this thing where the double
standards stay intact and i think that i
think the trump just implicitly gets
that
yeah i mean there's also a perverse
logic to it by the way which is
the democrats have no standards anymore
right there's no
the left has no standards anymore and so
the only thing to be judged on
is hypocrisy but if you have any
standards at all
right then you say okay hypocrisy that's
a bad thing but there are these other
bad things too and you don't but right
but but everything else
is good to go exactly exactly so
thank you you know about that one and
and about time
you know i try i get one every five
years one every five years i come up
with one that's a good one
so the the convention's okay fine the
conventions went well as they're leaving
though so that one convention the rnc
ends on the white house lawn because
you're not allowed to do it anywhere
else right so they do it on the white
house lawn
as people are leaving they get mobbed
they get absolutely the the people who
are congressmen senators
get mobbed by blm and antifa to the
point that
rand paul at one point is grabbing a cop
to help the cop because the cop was
being attacked and
rand paul jumps and rain paul they try
to kill rand paul every six months and
he somehow survives
and so he's you know helping everybody
out but these were very provocative
situations
the rioters uh who were largely blm and
there was one very shrill white woman
uh uh targeted uh a
a congressman who lost his legs in
afghanistan
and were like threatening him and this
guy's obviously dealt with the taliban
he's not worried about these shrimps
but still very provocative situation
wait so this is at the end of the
convention they're just trying to get to
their cars like they're literally
jewels to their cars yeah they're
leaving the white house and did people
know that there were huge protests
outside
they you could hear them you could hear
them a little bit oh wow
and but there's that was the way out i
mean frankly it was the biggest show of
the
of any of the conventions was watching
this unfold in real time
but one thing that was so amazing is and
you might have seen this before you left
there was this phrase that kept cropping
up say her name
and they were talking about the killing
of brianna taylor which which by the way
we this was presented to us as this
woman was totally innocent and she had
no role in any of these crimes and
it was just a killing and a murder by
the police
turns out that wasn't true turns out
leaked court documents are now saying
that she was involved in these these
drug crimes she was part of this
enterprise
and so as always this is a much murkier
situation than anyone thought
they're screaming say her name at rand
paul
who authored a bill naming brianna
taylor and and trying to put an end to
no knock warrants
but they didn't care no one knew you're
bad no matter what it's not about
saying anybody's name so were were
people hurt were any like public
officials hurt
people were hassled about i mean you
know
they probably had to go buy a new suit
or something like that nobody was killed
fortunately nobody was really
and how did new york times and msnbc and
everybody else spin this one
so the white supremacists the whites
but you know what it is in there you
know what they do they try to be fair in
balance yes
when blm and antifa and the left go and
just unilaterally attack
conservatives they like to say that you
know
conservatives and leftists clashed
it was a clash yeah yeah it was a clash
you know if there were very fine people
on both sides i guess that's what
they're really saying yeah
so that was that was the end of the rnc
this ties in with the vp pick yeah
how are the poll numbers looking when
you when you left how were the poll
numbers looking
the poll numbers for by you like
presidential free yeah i think biden was
usually up by like
seven or nine points or something like
that yeah but wait before we just fully
do on
go on that was at the dnc oh there was
it was all virtual so there was no place
for people to destroy things
yeah so that was a really clever move by
them because their own base
that's what people don't understand the
base
wants to destroy the party and then
these pathetic
people like joe biden are trying to just
hold together the house that has already
been ransacked right so they're smart
actually to have not done a convention a
because he probably shouldn't be out
there in front of people
but but b because their own base would
have burned the freaking thing down and
how would the media
have then spun that you know what i mean
like the the blm
progressive marxist blah blah
bass they hate biden they hate kamala
yeah they hate hillary
they they hate anyone that could be
thought they hate pelosi yeah you know
they they like aoc
and i guess ill han and and they they
like squad right the squad
they like that and that thing will
destroy itself as we talked about before
but it was a pretty shrewd move then to
do it all virtually you know your
month away actually gave you a
perspective and i just did not
perspective man because it seemed to me
they had you know there had been
rumblings okay we're going to do it
virtually we're going to do it we still
didn't know is it going to be in
charlotte it's going to be jacksonville
is it going to be in milwaukee
i had just assumed because the left has
been so
aggressive against the conservatives
that it
that shutting down the conventions was
about shutting down the republican
convention
but no it's to keep your own base that
you've ginned up into
hating america and wanting to destroy
everything and i mean what did freaking
what's his name uh bootage edge
yeah the most vanilla nothing what was
he saying about bernie
you know you're going to burn down the
whole system that's what you want to do
remember that last debate before super
tuesday
you're going to burn down the whole
thing so they all knew i mean that's the
thing
they're all playing with fire and now
they've brought in
a fire captain with dementia this is a
problem
people but it but nothing they do can
stop it i i you know i've had a pretty
good track record these last couple
years yeah on on picking these things
nothing they do can stop it this thing
is going to destroy the entire party
and every sane liberal along with it and
it just
because they had already they were
talking about the democratic activists
we're talking about 1968 all over again
we're going to burn this thing down
right
so they shut it down there's no there's
no convention
no real convention you know in person
republicans a little bit at the white
house
so is there going to be voting are you
going to get to go to a ballot box on uh
november
so now that now we're really talking
about that i mean right before i went
off the big thing was mail in ballots
which i think is
the idea that with a pandemic and with a
race riots and
general state of chaos and nobody
believing anything the idea that we'd
suddenly
alter significantly our voting system
that seems uh as the kids say
problematic yes
that seems like you don't add in another
crazy element
unless the whole freaking game whatever
we're talking about here is designed to
just make everyone crazy all the time
and i think that
might just be possible and maybe it is
yeah so
they have been floating the polls
i think it was around seven to nine it
was seven to nine points in favor of
biden so
so that has that has shrunk but biden is
still leading nationally
the key here is that in the swing states
the gap has shrunk in some cases
statistically to nothing one one case
is minnesota yeah now minnesota you'll
recall
blue state minnesota is a wonderful
haven of peacefulness it's a it's a very
fast i remember
very peaceful haven of fire yeah oh the
new one by the way so when you left it
was
uh mostly peaceful protesters now they
can't hide the fact that the whole
country is on fire
so they say fiery but mostly peaceful
protests
fiery but mostly peaceful man for anyone
that didn't watch
our 1984 on prageru the book club video
they really should watch that because
this is what they do with language
basically us reading the newspaper yeah
even though 1984 by george orwell yeah
so in in minnesota very peaceful
uh the polls have shrunk such that trump
and
and biden are basically in a dead heat
ronald reagan won 49 states in 1984
he didn't win minnesota minnesota is a
stubborn
state and now they're running even and
where's the next riot in wisconsin
so it creates this problem doesn't it
that the the riots which
have clearly been encouraged by the
democratic party and you've got
videos of ayanna presley of of hillary
clinton
of nancy pelosi all these people saying
yeah go out burn it down maxine waters
mob
people get in the streets chris cuomo
protests don't have to be peaceful
well they've encouraged it but now
wherever the protest
protests the riots are happening trump's
numbers are doing great yeah and biden's
numbers are going down this is this is
the fatal flaw of what they're doing by
playing with fire literally
the average person the average person
who's not purely political
the average person that just has a job
and wants to raise kids and have a house
and that's it and you know
play video games or whatever the hell it
is they do with their free time yeah
if their choice is oh we can either burn
the whole thing down
literally we will watch our stores burn
down we will watch the economy collapse
we'll watch the whole system
just crumble in front of us or orange
man who's a little weird with the hair
and he talks kind of funny and the
twitter
they're going to all choose that it's
just so obvious
now i'm not saying that's really what
the choice is but if that's what we're
being
given if that's what if that's what the
the funnel has
you know the funnel of ideas or whatever
you want to say has just like left us
with these choices
yeah one or the other i i think you're
probably
i will say it right now i think we could
be looking at a reagan reelection
situation
we actually could and it's this odd
thing where
what you have to ask yourself and maybe
you have inside because you're a
at least a former democrat or i guess
still a registered democrat
why would the democrats encourage these
riots
that are going to kill their poll
numbers because they don't the
because the new democrats the
progressives
people can't understand that i was in it
so i know what it is that's why i was
able to like
yeah do whatever it is that i've done
over these last couple years like
they they don't believe any of this is
good
they that is the fundamental truth now i
don't think i think biden thinks that
this is fundamentally good
yeah yeah but he's lost at this point
like he's just the old vestige
trying to hold the thing together and
he's like physically lost no he doesn't
know what we're yeah which is sad by the
way
you know what i mean like even we could
make all the jokes we want about that
but it's it's actually
sad that someone on on what clearly or
the beginnings of dementia or some other
cognitive decline
has been thrust into this position and
whether he even knows it or not
or is being used but i was saying months
ago that
you if you're a biden supporter you have
to know
you're voting for the vice president
you're not voting
for joe biden obviously but they have
unearthed something here
that man it's it's bad
well because it's really bad so they're
encouraging nationwide mailing that's
the big
the big uh scam seems like that would be
the easiest way to manipulate
votes doesn't it if you were going to do
it manipulate votes
super easy what would be the best way
what are you saying are you saying that
just because in california when i get my
ballot it actually has my political
party
listed on the ballot you saying just
because you can go harvest votes from
senior citizen homes are you saying just
because there was major male voter fraud
in in new jersey that we saw just a
number of weeks ago
are you saying they might steal the
election that way well as you know i i
just moved
and uh several times in the last year i
took
videos and i posted screen captures of
people literally stealing mail out of my
mailbox
yeah i'm not saying they were harvesting
ballots i don't know what they were
doing if they were just kids trying to
find credit cards
who the hell knows what they were but
the point is like if you want to make
the system
even more weak or have even more people
not trust the system
then you would alter the system right
before an election ugh
so oh great we want to hear the craziest
part of that we got a lot of work to do
we got a lot of work to do and who and
the here's the trouble though
and there was a local news station that
did an experiment to see how the mail-in
ballots were oh i saw that
yeah yeah that was right before i went
right brilliantly it was great right and
then what's the result of it they mail
them in yeah they get two birthday cards
so i don't know
some wireless card they lost three out
of 100 ballots yeah
that throws an election three percent
throws an election right
so you go into that already you got 80
to 100 million
voters expected to vote by mail this is
going to be a big problem
you're not going to know the results on
election night that's guaranteed right
people are going to blow past the
deadlines it's going to take too long
so already you've got this
constitutional crisis
this is what's so perverse about it
though
the democrats who pushed for this insane
corrupt
mail-in thing are now accusing president
trump of trying to steal the election
how
through the mail through the mail
because
they saw that there was a a mailbox that
had been moved in burbank california i'm
not joking
they looked at california you know that
is huge
trump's strong ikea is in burbank yes i
can maybe piece this thing together no
that's true you're right yeah
they they actually will take that
photograph and say well because a
mailbox was closed in burbank
trump is trying to steal the election
through the
vulnerable mechanism that we have been
foisting on the country
you know what it feels like to me
reality is now on trial
that's that's basically where we're at
that's where we're at
is that reality is on trial um when we
were driving over here today
yeah david was saying to me you know uh
you're gonna sit down with holes and get
all this like
how do you feel about all this and i was
kind of like
not nervous i don't get nervous for any
of these things but like
this i had this vision that we would be
in this position where you would say
like a whole bunch of things to me
and then it would all be like well okay
we're all just gonna
view the world very differently than
each other yeah you'll find
some people in your world who will view
the world in a similar way and hopefully
you'll be able to strengthen bonds with
them and maybe build community with them
and all those things
but then there's going to be this whole
other side and this goes for both sides
right
um there'll be like this whole other
community that will just believe
completely reverse things and that's why
reality is on trial it's like how do we
do something now jordan used to talk
about this all the time when we were on
tour
that you want a healthy left and right
you want conservatism
fighting for the old traditions that are
good versus liberals that are gonna
push new ideas forward you don't want
the thing to snap
and then just go one way or the other
you don't even a hardcore conservative
does
i think in their truest sense probably
doesn't want purely that
yeah someone would allow it we've been
country before you know i would allow
i'd have obviously 99
conservatives and maybe one libertarian
no yeah that'd be fine
you'd like one guy to be able to smoke
pot on his
doorstep and yeah that'd be kind of fun
to have every so often but man we are we
are in a reality war
i i think that's right you know we call
it the culture war but i think it's
starting to become the reality war that
seems to me where we're at
and the issue that you have i don't know
if the first one of these happened
before you went off the grid but you had
an image of an msnbc reporter
standing in front of a burning oh ali
velshi yes yeah yeah alive she's
standing in front of thing there's
nothing to see
here it's mostly peaceful uh dude
there's a building exploding
on fire yeah we got another one on cnn
about a week ago we got another
it was the same thing it was like you
could have just swapped the reporters it
was the exact same thing
same story but do you see why they can't
stop they can't stop because they're in
so deep that to stop to stop that wheel
that we were talking about before
they would have to they'd they'd have to
commit harry carey yeah you know what i
mean they'd have to just impale
themselves on their own swords
that would be the only way they would
have to say yes we have
been [ __ ] artists epic
[ __ ] artists decades speaking of
[ __ ] arts like is the new york times
still a newspaper or did that thing wrap
up
it was i mean it was crumbling i don't
think it's been a newspaper they had
announced they weren't going to do news
anymore they were going to run it by
like a seventh grader
so yeah the trans seventh grader was
gonna be able to correct things
something like that yeah all of the
editors of the new york times now have
to be trans seventh graders and you you
have to trans all the kids well actually
yeah so the new york times
is still whatever it is i'm not going to
say it's a newspaper but it's still
whatever it is
but on on the school front there is some
really weird stuff going on
so oh right are schools opening like
what's going on there do we have schools
anymore so let's look at new york
obviously giant school system
i come from the new york public you come
from as dwelling
right so new york has
no plan to reopen restaurants nope no
plan
they said maybe june of next year they
just don't know they're just
shooting from the hip however schools
are going to be back in session it was
just today it was delayed
so now they're going to push it it was
supposed to already start wait so
schools are not starting in new york
next
well i guess it would be today it would
be or today and they have delayed it but
they
they didn't they got a lot of flack for
saying the schools have to reopen
and no one understood why are the
schools it made perfect sense to me
you still want to indoctrinate the kids
you've placed a warehouse
to push you know it got so
weird that in outside of new york you go
to
durham north carolina the durham public
school system has
half a dozen schools they are they close
their schools schools are not reopening
okay
so instead what they're doing it's all
online learning but they are
operating six learning centers
and the learning centers are going to
allow kids to come in
and you know with their laptops and do
the online learning
do you know where the learning centers
are
the learning centers at prison what no
well county prison sort of the learning
centers
are in the schools which are closed
no but it gets better dave it gets
better because wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i
know it's hard because i'm just getting
back on the grid so maybe my english
isn't maybe
what you're telling me is durham has
closed the schools
then they've announced that these
centers will open where the kids can
come with their laptops to do remote
learning to do remote learning and that
is at the schools that are closed that's
correct
yeah makes sense doesn't it but actually
what you're probably saying is though
the only way that would
work is if the school district charged
the parents more money to come use the
schools which are closed to do the
online learning from the schools that
you can't go to right
that would that would make sense so in
order to use the
remote learning centers at the schools
parents have to pay
a hundred forty dollars a week plus a
thirty five dollar registration fee
unless you're a bureaucrat who works for
the government in which case you get a
discount
what's the what's the daily wire uh
policy on f word
uh oh it's it's your show my friend yeah
we are at your house
it's [ __ ] insane but again
do you see what i'm saying that there is
nothing too stupid for this movement
yeah there is nothing too insane for
this movement it
it will eat away and rot out ev whatever
institution allows this stupidity in
it will destroy it yeah and that is what
it sounds like is happening
in durham north carolina speaking but
wait a minute yeah why would they need
more money to do that i assume
everyone's still paying taxes they
didn't
tax rebates to the people they're all
still paying taxes so you're paying the
exact amount of taxes that you always
paid for the public schools the public
schools are then closed but then less
people will be there correct so you'd
think you would be able to save a little
money yeah
but then you still got to charge them so
now so in effect only people with money
will be able to send their kids to those
schools
but i thought they're also against
school choice and they're also my brain
is exploding
here's the way to make sense of it has a
government agency
ever said give me less money yeah
has that ever happened in the history of
humanity no they run
literally i mean people don't believe
this but most government agencies run on
a thing where they have to hit their
budget otherwise their budget gets cut
nobody could run a business like that i
can't run my business like that
where i'm like i have to spend every
freaking cent that i have
yeah otherwise i'm not gonna magically
get well because i'm not giving money i
have to earn money yeah
you know so i so what i do is i save a
certain amount in my business each year
so we can continue to grow
or we might have some problems and then
we can figure out that's
that's completely foreign yeah that's
completely foreign to a government an
economic genius over here i know you are
and you know actually
speaking of kind of naughty words going
blue yeah i have to read you there is a
song
that is i'll just bust out your glasses
like i wish excuse me sir
now that we're going blue so there's a
new song that's taken over the world
and when i say taking over the world i
mean like this is the story
okay this is like the story yeah so
i don't even know you know i don't go
blue on my show yeah i don't know
clean clean cut i don't wear socks in my
loafers you know i try to be
i can't say the name of this of this
song without going blue
would it be better and you're hosting
right now so i want you to do what you
think is right would it be better if
if i just read it straight up i would
feel much better if you
so the song is called whap okay
right yeah w.a.p
okay it's by cardi b and this one i mean
this is like
now the the anthem the feminist anthem
right and cardi b
i'm not totally sure who she is but i
know she was like fighting with people
right before i went yes
she she supported bernie sanders
i think she and i think that's racist
for you to say but yes she does have
long tails
so here's so this is this song's just
taken over everyone's this is everyone's
taken over
so i'll just i guess i'll just read a
little yeah [ __ ]
in this house there's some [ __ ] in
this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house
hole up i said certified freak seven
days a week
wet ass [ __ ] make that pull-out game
weak
that's good and then the chorus yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you [ __ ] with some sweet ass
[ __ ]
bring a bucket and mop for this [ __ ]
mop
for this oh bring a bucket and mop for
this
you got to mop up them uh give me
everything you got for this wet ass
[ __ ]
uh i'm gonna not do the next paragraph
because that's where they'll come for me
yeah this is the so so where does she
get her mop
yeah you can't that's got some words
that you're not allowed to you know yeah
so that song i mean she's making a point
it's not she's making not without merit
no it's not it actually i
th the song actually does have a point
the thesis of the song
is that all women are prostitutes
that's actually the thesis she says yeah
i got my man by
and she describes sexual acts that i
know look we're young hit millennials
okay we've done also
like that you've never thought of i mean
in this kind of
it's i didn't know that pornography
having a slot bucket
it's like just that image i didn't know
that
that audio could be pornographic i
thought pornography is only visual yeah
it's audio but the it's a really s
you could only they would only do it for
to get sexual pleasure
she says i put different wigs on all the
time because my man wants to cheat on me
and so i've got to allow him to feel
like he's cheating on me so she's saying
that these things are
good like this is how you attain power
in essence it's not yes
it's right she's not which is so the
root it's so the reverse
actually of what what at least first
wave feminism
was all yeah yeah it's it's a it's funny
because it's such a ridiculous song but
it is a commentary on our
map i see and it then it hits you
it took me like a day to i thought oh as
i'm pondering this deep song of great
singing
yeah and but that's it that and
so to say that calling women prostitutes
and having them sell themselves is
empowering is is obviously a complete
reversal of reality like you say reality
is on trial
it's emblematic to me of everything
that's going on another example do you
know bella thorne have you ever heard of
bella thorne
she's some movie star she was she was a
tv star something like that okay
what was she in doing she i don't know
something like it wasn't going with the
wind i tell you okay it wasn't the
godfather okay
bella thorne goes on onlyfans.com
onlyfans.com is this way to democratize
porn
anyone can go on it and she does it and
she sells nude photos
some hacker hacks into her stuff takes
the nude photo she says well i'm going
to just sell it
200 a pop 200 a pop for a nude photo on
the internet that's outrageous
she makes million bucks in the first day
2 million bucks within the week
but i guess the photos were not
sufficiently nude so then the customers
were demanding a refund from only fans
it became a big issue
so then only fans stopped so they don't
know what they're buying no
they don't know they knew it was a nude
photo but it's all blurry or something
and so they get the photos they want the
demand they didn't see the whap
they didn't they didn't get the whap
cardboard would be very dismayed yeah
and so now only faces in the whole
problem
they they make a cap it's only fifty
dollars now per nude photo
and now the prostitute's on only fans
are very upset because
they previously were able to get a lot
of money for their photos and
they'll show the web because they'll
show the web and they figured i'd get
300 400 i don't know i don't know what
they charge
yeah bella thorne issues an apology to
the pornographers and the prostitutes
because she drove down their business
and it just occurred to me
every single person in this situation
did the wrong thing
isn't that a beautiful thing when
everyone can screw up something so
perfectly it's actually kind of
miraculous
yeah so she because she didn't show in
effect the wow
apologizes to the people who show the
whap only fans
drops the price the cap yeah
so that she so that basically she can't
blow the those guys out of the water so
to speak as it were
and now well this is you know i think
we're mixing metaphors but they are
creating a lot of images yes
and lest you think that a movie star
who's already a millionaire
going on and trying to make another
quick couple million by becoming a
pornographic actress
yeah unless you think the whap unless
you think all of that is
the bottom of our sexual decay yeah
what's the last sexual taboo in the
world
especially at least in our country
what's the last episode you shouldn't
bang a goat
are you sure how dare you yeah how dare
you shouldn't be going
i don't want to i'm not holier than now
but don't bang it look at me i'm no
bible thumbnail but
yeah it would seem to me i mean maybe
the goat thing is still a little taboo
yeah the last thing is kids right yeah
kids can even the most insane leftists
again i would think even the most insane
leftists say kids are off limits
wherever this is going wherever we're
going right now
netflix i'm not talking about some
crazy website in the depths of the
internet i'm not i'm not talking about
jeffrey epstein's plane
netflix posts a movie
it's called cuties and the picture the
poster is
of 11 year olds pre-teens
twerking and here's the description
amy 11 becomes fascinated with a
twerking dance crew
hoping to join them she starts to
explore her femininity
defying her family's traditions
i'm guessing her family is a christian
family muslim awesome that's interesting
muslim which is kind of interesting it's
a french movie ah okay because
because there are no christians left in
france yeah there it's all the only
religious people are the muslims yeah
that would not have come out of
america um you know the the
positive thing here is yeah there was
blowback they said you know
twerking 11 year olds is a little too
far
but the fact that that could make it
onto netflix with that poster with that
description
how did we get here it's not even goats
if
i if you had told me the goat thing i'd
say oh that's wholesome now compared to
cuties and i'm pretty sure uh didn't rob
schneider bang a goat in an adam sandler
movie
that would make sense yeah hopefully i
think it was a movie
yeah let's say yeah it was a movie
um yeah i mean nothing surprises me like
that that's what i'm saying
when i say there's a war on reality it's
like it's almost like we're getting
we're sort of in a boy who cried wolf
but it's but it's like more perverse
than that because it's almost like we
need more
shock value every day yeah to keep us
going and again that gets back to that
that rat race thing it's like there is
we've done this all down and we've made
it all so crazy
that i was reading you know one of the
things that i read over the last month i
read common sense by thomas paine
and a bunch of his other writings and
it's like i
was in the middle of one of the
paragraphs i stopped and i was like my
god
if a politician spoke like this yeah
three sentences in a row like this we'd
be like
he must be insane there's an insane
person here because
he was actually trying to talk about
honest things
with common sense right it's right in
the title right common sense i just get
i mean i i'm with you in that nothing
surprises me anymore yeah
you know if if i find as you say if i
found out coronavirus doesn't even exist
i'd say like huh okay yeah i guess so
whatever
but it just seemed to me like kids you
know that i
you'd think that's off limits but when
you see the kind of craziness with
shutting down the schools
shutting down you know the the all of
these kind of drag
nine-year-olds and whatever all these
kind of things it has been building such
that there are no more taboos but the
way you put it is so right
which is you're in that hamster wheel
you got to get a little more you got to
go a little faster you've got to get
more
uh insanity yeah well it's like
when i say it's a reality war it's like
a thought war sort of so it's like
i was even i tweeted out that we're
doing this right now but i haven't
looked at twitter yet i haven't looked
at my feed obviously and i haven't
looked at my mentions but if you think
about what twitter is which drives so
much of this
right this thing that we're talking
about twitter is just people having
thoughts all day long and the second
they have
thought thoughts and you're banging
these thoughts all around all day long
and someone across the world who you've
never heard of could say have a thought
that has no value in any way but could
somehow
trigger you into launching an attack on
them and then next thing you know
there's a problem at the
embassy and some you're like we're in a
it is the matrix we're in it now man
we're there
that it's so it's is so fast and
i mean do you i kind of was at least
hoping on this
everything's moving too quickly that the
lockdowns would slow things down a
little bit
no but it's exacerbated it's exhausting
because if we already had a pr we had a
problem with big tech we had a problem
with information we had a problem with
truth um and then what did we do
we said oh the vehicles that you get all
this information they're going to become
exponentially more important to you
meaning you don't go to a bar anymore to
meet a stranger to talk about things
yeah
you only will do it online and then we
haven't even talked about this at all
but i assume
uh nobody's censoring anyone on the
internet anymore oh that must have been
not at all
no that's over that must have oh no you
did tell me earlier that
uh you can't say certain things on
twitter and you can't i mean well yeah
i'll give you i'll give you a great
example of one i mean the
a lot of it's covid related i mean i've
had i've had my show taken down parts of
it have been taken down
say you know dangerous guys i'm a
dangerous guy i'm very intimidating as
you can
tell bucket and whatever else you've got
over there i'm carrying my mop
i'm gonna get you uh so there was a
study that just came out of revolver
just yesterday actually
so you just missed breaking news this is
breaking news yeah
it was an academic study that
ascertained how many lives were saved by
the lockdown
and how many lives were cost by the
lockdown and
and the way they measured it was human
life years
so a year a year of human life for
anybody right it could be for
you know for grandma or for the kid or
whoever so the good news is
that the lockdown saved a quarter to
three quarters of a million human life
years right the bad news is
the lockdown itself caused 10 times
as much in terms of human life years
meaning meaning because people are
drinking more and
drinking drug overdoses depression
problems
suicide all these sorts of things the
lockdown according to this
study academic study is ten times
deadlier than the virus
i think you and i were floating that
idea two months ago yeah well
you know that crazy guy who works in
this building that shapiro guy
what did he trend on twitter for a
little bit before i went off
when he said what we all know to be true
which is what actuaries do every day
by you know guarding risk versus reward
in essence that
we are going as a society we are going
to have to decide
what amount of people being sick or what
amount of people dying
is acceptable not we don't want it yeah
yeah but it's the simple truth
to what is acceptable for us to then
continue
with human society as it has always
continued it's a question of risk right
it's just risk that's all it is he
wasn't
he wasn't um he actually mentioned it on
my show i was doing a live stream with
him and that was and then it was people
it was the number one trend on on
twitter that day but all these people
were saying
shapiro wants all these people to die
and he's going to kill grandma and all
this stuff and it's like no that's
just what insurance companies do you
know you pay a certain amount in and
their hope is
that you're going to pay more in than
you're going to take out if you get
really sick i mean these are just
obvious realities but now even to say
those obvious realities we
we can't say those realities because if
you even say that they'll say you want
to kill grandma even though we all
we all know it's true well you you have
to have some risk in society right what
are we going to do next flu season
right flu season's coming up right what
are we going to do then
you remember why aren't we all why
aren't we all on the streets going crazy
i mean that when i tell you that the
street's already falling the other guy's
going crazy
we are all yeah sorry we are in the
streets going crazy but i guess for
something else
but like this idea that i just because i
moved i was walking around the
neighborhood and there's some nice
restaurants that are there that i had
never seen before and i'm looking
they're all closed
yeah and it's like that we've taken away
it's not just that you can't go to a
restaurant it's that somebody started
that restaurant there was a little
italian
trottery by me and i walked by it looked
so nice inside like had a little bar
that you'd go to just have a glass of
wine and
uh like just some fun old italian
posters and things
and i was like this is the type of place
i would love to walk to and and be fun
and it's like
somebody built that place yeah that was
somebody's life that was somebody's
livelihood probably their family all
those things
we've just ripped that away from people
and i'm not saying again that i'm not
saying it's a hoax but the the cost on
the other side
yeah is like why are we afraid to talk
about that why are we afraid to
push back and say sorry gavin newsom or
whoever
or andrew cuomo or whoever you don't get
to decide whether i'm going to have a
life that has purpose or not yeah well
yet we seem to be and speaking of cuomo
so cuomo uh
implemented i actually don't know i
don't know if he implemented it before
he left but he certainly
uh maintained it the quarantine yeah oh
i think you're gonna say remember when
he did the thing
which was right before i went off where
you could be at a bar but then certain
but wings don't count as
food because you have to order food at a
bar and then people started ordering
wings to get away with it yeah but wait
and then
decided wings isn't a meal wings are a
meal wings are totally amazing wings are
a meal of course
you want media yeah i've got to eat
zucchini sticks or something yeah it's
like michelle obama over here but like
they say that but that even that type of
thing
it's like a politician announces that
wings aren't a meal literally this is
not a we're not making this up
because it decides you said the buffalo
wings are not a meal and we just
accept that okay now i can't go to a bar
and have wings
because they can't put a sandwich as a
meal or something and it's like what
does that have to do with you being
governor what what are you governing
over well this this issue of
cuomo we're gonna we're gonna follow the
science we're gonna follow the data and
the science
and so as a result of this he said that
if you traveled in to new york from
terrible places like california
you'd have to quarantine for two weeks
so if we were to go to new york we're
gonna go to new york after quarantine
obviously no one is doing this
but they are they're handing out fines
if you if you violated are they really
yeah so that's that's insane china level
stuff
so trying to and it's just a cash grab
and a power grab so they and then the
cdc
which is our public health
administration governing body
they take away this guideline they say
okay it is no longer advised that you
need to have this quarantine
so cuomo takes away the quarantine right
uh
no i don't think so he says absolutely
not i'm going to defer to the science
he said well hold on the cdc they're the
aren't they the scientists and you're
just this like
bulldog-faced governor of new york and
he says no that science has been
politicized
so now the left is complaining about
politicized science nothing is true
nothing nothing matters no matter what
this is one of the things this is where
we've talked about this many times
what my frustrations are with my last
remaining liberal friends is they seem
to think
that there will be some point yeah that
it will get so nutty with the left
that at some point logic and reason will
be forced to be accepted
yeah but that is the reverse of how this
thing will work every time
they're proven wrong about something
they double down in it more because it
proves to them that the system is evil
you understand like right instead of
when like for example
so trump became president trump in a
sane world would probably not be
president
but you'd think that the lefties would
have been like man maybe we really did
screw some things up maybe we should
think about ourselves
right and think about it and that's by
the way i was doing a million videos
about that because i was considered
myself a lefty at the time and going
guys we
should rethink this as lefties what are
we doing and return to the roots of
liberalism
but what i found was all they wanted to
do it was
proof that they were right the loss was
proof that they were right
so everything forces them to double down
into their own [ __ ]
or crapulence as mr burns might say
everything for
everything is a proof a further proof of
their theory as opposed to oh what would
what would a rational person do or a
businessman do or someone that has to be
functional in society
you keep doing things that screw up you
might go oh maybe i am doing something
wrong but they actually operate on the
reverse
thesis this is a problem and this is
also it gets to what andy cuomo means by
science
i like that you call him andy and anyone
else new yorkers
you know i i've met andrew cuomo on two
occasions
i was once his waiter and on the other
time he caught me outside smoking a
cigar and drinking a beer during
hurricane sandy it's true story
he caught you he personally caught me
and what did he do he yelled out
as well as my as my drunken friends
who had been drinking beers while the
stormrage uh we went outside had a cigar
i don't want i need a cigar
but it's a hurricane we go outside and
andrew cuomo
we call him andy his friends uh we hear
what the hell are you kids doing
and they say all right for a walk not a
good night for that we turn around and
it's andy cuomo
with two cops one cop on either side and
it was like getting caught by teacher
because you're like ah [ __ ] yeah i don't
think this is like
we're not supposed to be doing this and
luckily he had other other things to
tend to so he didn't didn't arrest us or
anything like that
he didn't throw you in the slammer he
didn't throw us in the slammer but cuomo
actually makes a little bit of sense
when he says i'm following the science
because what the left means by science
is not
looking under a microscope and
discovering stuff about viruses what
they mean is the same thing karl marx
meant
hegel and all these kind of thinkers
that have come in their wake
woodrow wilson which is the science of
history
it's like obama's so he talks about the
right side of history right they believe
that
that they have found scientific
precision in history
they know the end of history and so
whatever they want to do
is the scientific thing to do and
whenever they lose an election by the
way
it is by definition illegitimate because
you're they're not supposed to lose
elections that's i mean that
what did people think was gonna happen
when a bunch of us were like hey you
know if you
if you have a penis you're a male and
they said you're a bigot or you're scary
i don't know what the hell they said but
but they were all making it sound like
oh it's just a bunch of us crazy people
on youtube
saying that this stuff matters yeah when
they go for this and yet now we're
seeing it
now we're seeing it oh well if that
doesn't matter by the way wasn't there
is there some law being passed someone
passingly mentioned this to me so i
sense something might be happening in
california now
where they're actually trying to
institute racial quotas at companies or
something like that so oh it's so much
yeah so someone sort of said something
to me and then i was like you got to say
this is so much worse than that before
you even tell me i just want to be very
clear
on this one i will never hire someone
based on the color of their skin
or their sexuality or their gender oh so
you're about to call me a racist
call me a bigot call me homophobe call
me a nazi yeah
but i i won't and i really mean that i
will never i have two companies i will
never hire someone
you're telling me that you won't judge
someone based on the color of their skin
rather than the content of their
character i won't knows i don't care
what the threat is that's like i'll put
ice in my mouth for that too
that's very dramatic lawyers come that
was yeah that's oh he was mumbling
i couldn't know what did he quite say
yeah so it's it's so much worse than
that in california and
i know you just got a house in
california you might you want to
so let me just address this real quick i
did decide to stay um
i was thinking about leaving you and i
actually we had several dinners where we
we both discussed it um i decided to
stay
and and it was there were several things
career-wise and everything else
happening but what i really thought
would
really boil down to more than anything
else more than the weather yeah or any
of that stuff was that
if someone like me cannot live here
cannot live in california like like it's
become so extreme that someone like me
can't live there
then the american experiment the union
the states the
the whole federal project then it really
is over and then really what we're
saying
is okay we're at civil war like the
states really
are going to just fray and if you
believe this you'll live here and if you
believe that this you'll be here i i'm
not willing to give that up yet
and i will uh tell you one other thing
which is that during all this i watched
on netflix
while i was off the grid i watched this
two-part documentary on netflix it
wasn't
cutie pie or whatever that was yeah yeah
it was a frank sinatra documentary two
two hour episodes it was
phenomenal and i love the old crooners
and all that yeah
and one of the interesting things about
sinatra that you forget about because of
the voice and because of the rat pack
and yeah and all that
stuff is that he was a huge democrat
for a long time fundraiser campaigned
for democrats
with jfk friends with jfk they really go
into that and one of the things that
happened to frank sinatra
was frank sinatra because he was also a
californian became a californian
republican
for ronald reagan and then the media
started going after him and a lot of the
documentaries about this
how awful the media was and he he has
some great quotes about the media that
you're like holy [ __ ] the guy was saying
this 40 years ago
about how evil they are and they just
want to destroy people and all this
stuff but he has a great line
that almost it's almost a quote of
himself from uh from my way
yeah the song my way where he's like
every man has a duty
to vote the way their conscience falls
vote for who they believe in and and you
have a right and a duty to do that as an
american
and it's like that sounds like a brave
thing to say now
and i suppose it was a brave thing to
say then but of course you have that
right
and duty why am i even telling you all
this well how is this
oh because of the year because of
california because i think you've made
a good a good argument to stay in
california
but you haven't seen what's been coming
up in the california legislature
you a business owner am i going to have
to fire myself is that you are
definitely going to have to fire
yourself so obviously everyone's going
to have to have a slot bucket for the
[ __ ]
they're going to need to have they're
going to need it's not a slot bucket so
much
as a collection bucket that's going to
come around now
they're going to raise your taxes we all
knew that right you can't you can't shut
down the state the fifth largest economy
in the world for
for however long and not have anybody
pay for that
they're also talking about a wealth tax
and there's a
some people you know they just hear tax
and it's all we're not talking about
taxes on your
income we're talking about taxes on the
not only the money that you already have
but the assets that you already yeah
let's say you have a house house is a
half a million dollars
they can come in and say well you're
worth half a million dollars we want a
piece of that so write me a check for 50
grand
but you don't have 50 grand you've just
got you got a house or you got a car or
whatever
that's what's being floated right now
and i'll do you one better
it's not just on the money you've got if
you leave california
they could hit you with this for up to
10 years
for up to 10 years so you leave the
bananas
you go to let's say texas no state
income tax
yeah then they can for 10 years go after
whatever i assume the oh it's the assets
i guess that you had and
yeah so this is being this is what's
being discussed right now obviously
nothing's been
finalized yet but when i look at that
bananas is an aft word because
that is some banana republic stuff i
mean that's the stuff they do in
venezuela
but now you're seeing it in california
in the united states and
it's supposedly the civilized state the
giant economy
so i got stuff to do you got stuff i i
got stuff to do by staying i mean i i
really
i'm not just saying that to be glib or
to sound like i'm
uh doing something noble or something
but like
this stuff needs to end these horrible
ideas need to end
because think about it if everyone else
moves if all the good people move
imagine if we end up in that situation
you think it's polarized now
yeah what happens when california fully
goes bankrupt
and then the feds are under pressure the
fed is now under pressure
to bail it out every single person in
texas who lived in
within their means is going to want to
kill people from california
and you wouldn't even have you wouldn't
be able to blame them so we we have to
fix some of this from the inside
ronald reagan was governor of california
before he was president
arnold schwarzenegger was a republican
governor of california not that long ago
yeah like maybe some of this stuff can
get fixed and i'm going to
freaking try to pick some of it or you
know
you'll die trying because because there
is this real worry i mean
you have a bunker i've got a bunker yeah
you come downstairs i mean there is this
worry that before you left
you know people are talking about i hope
these riots finally abate i mean they've
been going on for months now yeah
but they they've only gotten worse yeah
and i mean we mentioned a little bit
earlier this case of
kyle rittenhouse this guy who defended
himself with the gun now they're saying
it's open warfare
the president's defending him but you
know up until now it's really only been
left-wing violence and now you've got a
right-winger defending himself against
the left-wing violence and it's not just
people getting knocked out
this does kind of remind you a little
bit of the 1850s right i mean whenever
people have brought up civil war i've
just thought
no it's not going to happen but if even
in the month you've been gone things
have gotten
so much worse there have been videos
that have come out in just the past week
or so
of uh of people posting they say white
lives don't matter and it's a young
black guy goes up to a middle-aged white
guy knocks him in the head with a brick
there was a story that just came out a
couple of days ago a
black customer at autozone goes up to
the middle-aged white employee just
stabs him starts stabbing him and when
he was asked why did he do it he said
i watched a bunch of videos on the
internet
of police brutality and i felt i had to
go out there and kill a white guy
but i thought youtube radicalizes
everyone to the alt-right it's oh [ __ ]
that's what the new york times said with
my picture on the that's right you are
the gateway to the alt-right or you're
the
you're a neo-nazi white supremacist but
actually
we now have firm evidence of all of
these social media platforms
radicalizing people toward the left
toward racial division toward racial
hatred
how do you come back from there because
yeah well that that's what we have to do
but you bring up the big tech issue
that's the issue right
because it's not just the democrats
egging people on it's not just antifa or
blm
it's it's not just technology it's not
just the universities it's
all of it working together what do we do
now
well you're asking me the big one
knowles that's the big one oh i want to
know what you've been going for
yeah well what do we do i mean i think
the only thing you can do is
is try to be a little better than them
incrementally and
as you are i think most people aren't
horrible people i don't think most
people want the world to burn i don't
think most people want to control
everybody i don't think most people
want to take from you and and give to
someone else i think
all of these bad ideas have have
manifested themselves and and
um bubbled up because good people are
just afraid to say what they think
yeah and i mean i i
literally wrote a book about it like
yeah you gotta you gotta be
more brave you can't leave it up to
you know that crazy michael knowles yeah
and dave rubin to
to do it you gotta do it in your own
life and start fighting for what you
believe in like it's
who what's the quote it's only a country
if you have it or something right yeah
yeah
that's the the franklin quote yeah give
me something yeah it's uh
a republic if you can keep it yeah like
can you remember that the question
actually
speaking of the book i was wondering
this if you're not in the news i mean my
nose is buried in it all day you say
that your phone is not by your bed and
that mine is it's the first thing i look
at it's the last thing i thought you
nothing here today
i know tonight maybe don't sleep with
your friend i have to i've got to lock
it away in a safe hopefully forever you
know what did you do
what do you do with all that time
literal well so we moved which obviously
obviously and we rebuilt my studio which
we'll debut tomorrow and that was a ton
of there's just like stuff
yeah just stuff and bringing in lighting
people and tech people and
doing all that kind of stuff so there
was that yeah um but i was really aware
of just
trying to like just sort of trying to be
yeah i mean i got up every morning i did
the same thing every single morning i
have coffee before i usually pee then i
have
coffee and then i did about an hour of
cardio every single day watching my old
basketball games and there was no
racial problems or anything it was just
about basketball weird sports being
about sports very bizarre so odd
um i take my take my dog for a lot of
long walks
you've met clyde he's a little banana
he's got some boxer in him so he really
needs long walks so long walks
um we ate really well like we cooked i
didn't eat out
even once i we ordered in maybe i can't
even remember ordering in but maybe
oh we ordered sushi once but like we
cooked a lot and i grilled a lot and
like
that was you know i did some reading and
i played some basketball and that really
was
it i didn't do that much and i was
really okay
not doing that because you do wonder i
mean you think even
that's just for adults right adults are
going crazy if they stay locked in and
they you know
you got to do that you got to play
basketball you got to be able to
talk to people you gotta but now it's on
the kids too
so you know kids hadn't been wearing the
stupid masks
and now uh eric swalwell nearly the
president you know he was
so close that guy eric swalwell who is
you and me and all of us i believe that
campaign motto yeah eric swalwell tweets
out an
image of little kids in masks he says
you've got to do this for your
i think what are what are you telling
yeah what are you telling these kids
that you say you're three or
five-year-olds
all of a sudden you've got to put on
masks one new thing they're doing is
they put them in bubbles it's literally
bubble boy
they put them in this this weird
contraption which is so odd because
it's you know plastic all around but
it's open at the top but the kids are
like three feet tall so
if the spindle is going anywhere it's
going to go right down into the
contraption see the problem with
discussing this is i know already
there's some idiot at media matters or
somewhere that's going to clip this and
say
okay so here's ruben and knowles denying
coronavirus
we're not we're not what we're talking
about is what is it that you do in the
long-term health of a society
right when you just train everyone to
behave a certain way and do all of these
things that
for as much as we can tell aren't
necessarily scientifically proven
whether you have a box on someone's head
yeah with an opening up here
but that you just train children to just
follow orders like
robots and all of these things i'm much
more interested in that discussion than
whatever
like the the political machination of
the day is but but there's a certain set
of people out there that are making it
that it is their job and they are well
funded often
to to try to make sure we can't have
those conversations so you'll just
keep accepting it they'll keep feeding
you crap and you'll keep eating crap
because you'll forget
that's what i meant before about how
february seemed so long ago to us
it's like it really does try to remember
february
everything was pretty good yeah and
we're forgetting that things were pretty
good
there was impeachment in january
remember impeachment remember
impeachment yes
so we didn't there's no impeachment
happening right now there's not yet wait
until he gets reelected yeah
then you can see it i it's funny when
we're talking about the bubble boy and
the boxes and the whatever
i'm reminded of this this old left-wing
thinker
in the early part of the 20th century
this guy wilhelm wright she was a
psychologist
scientist and he developed this theory
that the whole
life energy of the universe was with
something called an orgone
that related to your orgastic potency
you want to talk about the whap
and basically that all the problems in
society
war poverty cancer everything was caused
by a lack
of orgasms this is what he believed and
he developed a box called the oregon
accumulator
which was later parodied as the
orgasmatron by yeah well
it sounds like he's going to need this
that's [ __ ] it you need
this this was an actual popular thing
norman mailer had the
orgasmatron the organic community you
got in a box
i don't know what went on in the box
what do you do you get you get
go in the box or go on the button no you
go in the box and then what you do in
the box is your business okay i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna make any judgments this
was a popular
scientific idea and when i look at the
ridiculous bubble boy when i look at all
these things i just think like
people are going to be making fun of
this in 50 years
but as of right now it's very serious
science we've all got to take it
super duper seriously do you think we
got to shake people out of the science
thing i mean you know now media matters
headlines going to be
reuben and knowles they're against
science they're against the box
they're against the box orgasmatron i
don't know um well i don't think we have
to shake people out of science i think
we have to shake
people into sense that that really is it
that is
it common sense yeah and
and living within your means and being a
decent person and all of the things
that we all know are obviously true and
yet we
we somehow i don't know we're i can see
it very clearly now after not being in
it
and and i'm really going to try to i've
tried
for the last while anyway but i'm going
to really try to to help people make
some sense out of this thing because
it's
the people that think it's just gonna
it's either they i think some people
think it's either gonna stop
or or that it will reset itself or
somehow that this
this messed up thing we're in right now
it can't be
like it can't last forever yeah well i
agree it can't last forever but it could
have it could last for decades
right you know you mean like nothing
lasts forever the the greatest
joys and freedoms don't last forever and
and the greatest
tyrannies and atrocities don't last
forever so whatever it is we're in right
now
which is neither one of those by the way
it's somewhere much more in between yeah
um it won't last forever but you might
be an agent
that could help fix it yeah you might be
there's only one way
to find out and there's you know even
things that you think will remain on top
and totally successful forever i think
of new york city
manhattan island well here's a new story
no it's not i mean it's not still a city
the city is completely shut down
it's empty and this is a news story that
you might have seen a little bit
just because you were moving the lined
to get u-holes in manhattan around the
block
completely people are fleeing from the
city
and are they gonna are they gonna go
back when are they gonna go back the
greatest city in the history of the
world yes the center
the center of the universe the center of
the universe uh i've mentioned this on
the show a couple times before when i
had giuliani on i mentioned it
yeah but there have been my family has
had at times dozens something like 60 or
70
reuben family members extended on either
side
living in new york city um since around
1908 something like that
uh there's one person left one person
left my sister and her husband and two
kids left in the middle of the pandemic
that took four people out and now and
then one cousin died
in the midst of the pandemic and then i
got one cousin left
in there that's just indicative of
what's happening what because what can
you do i mean they can only push you so
far
i i appreciate that you're making the
stand to save california i i hope we can
save it you know
but you can only push people so far and
they're gonna
they're going to react to that all these
businesses there's an estimated sixty
percent of american restaurants
gonna go out of business they're still
not reopened so i think one of the ways
that we get out of this is that
something will happen
and i don't i don't know what it is i
don't know what it is i could see it
having to be a horrific thing like
some sort of terrorist attack or
something horrible but maybe there's a
better way that
like it won't be the ultimate horror
that will shake us at us
something shakes us out of this and then
we could and
we could enter like a roaring 20s
situation
where everyone will want to be out and
about again they'll want to spend money
again they'll want to be like sort of
the better versions of themselves
again and we'll get over the fear and
the hate and all that stuff i don't know
what it takes to get there and there's
going to be
the forces that would rather that not
happen are probably far stronger than
the forces that could make that happen
yeah um but that that's one
sort of distant star to look at i
suppose and there there is this question
there have been all these kind of crazy
foreign stories people haven't paid a
ton of attention to them
but one i guess this isn't even a news
like lost over that piece in the middle
east thing that was
yeah that you know that was a pretty big
story yeah but obviously
it's too nice to trump so the media's
got to kill that but another one you
know in terms of threats
kim jong-un is he back didn't he
said maybe we don't he's now
maybe in a coma again remember he was
maybe in a coma before he left and now
he's maybe in a coma again
so we just don't know that's a very
volatile situation
china has been aggressing in india in
taiwan
in vietnam over japan it's been
aggressing all over the place on
american interests
right now let's say that china invades
they're not going to invade mainland
america but they invade some american
interests
well we're busy burning down our country
is there
is there any way we could fight a war
with china
well first off we don't want to fight a
war with china yeah that's number one
um well that sort of gets what i was
saying about like how do we get out of
this sort of thing like
like would it take something horrible
like does it take like a pearl harbor
or something so terrible to just like
for us to like
turn and look at the person who maybe is
our ideological opponent
yeah and say you're a human now what i
can say is that generally speaking in
the last two
years or so i have found that people on
the right are
are almost always almost without
exclusion willing
to do that of course willing to give
those guys the benefit of the doubt
right what i've seen on the left is
almost no willingness to do it and not
only that but if you see someone else on
the left that's willing to do it you go
and destroy them
um one of the things that i right before
i went off was um that guy matt taibi
who's a
journalist lefty lifelong lefty
journalist who suddenly
is saying you know something's wrong
with the left guys and i'm like yeah
hey hey remember me hi i'm dave rubin hi
yeah yeah
um but now what i remember from just the
day or two before i went was where there
were all these lefties going oh now he's
in it for that coke money
and the big right wing money and the and
the sell and it's something
yeah yeah yeah and it's like come on man
like this every time
someone says there's something wrong
here yeah if you go to destroy them well
then what you will be left with
is something that is very sick and
twisted and evil and and i think that
that's what
they have on their hands at the moment
and the question is do you go in and try
to
operate or do you just say this thing is
done
i mean that's what i think i think this
thing is done and there are better
places if you if you believe any of the
things that i believe and if you believe
in
old-school liberalism or you just think
america is decent or any of those things
like
there's a lot of bridges to build yeah
right in this freaking building that i'm
in right now
two nights ago if you were in the street
of a big city
yes you could have heard the phrase
death to america
now if i said you have to pick one stop
by it in slogan now that's gonna be
joe biden harris death to america
if you had to pick one city where you
actually put money down on it right
was that being chanted in tehran in the
in the middle east somewhere where they
hate us or was that being
chanted in oakland california where
would you put your money well oakland is
more of a radical hotbed of
spoolie nonsense it is it was in oakland
it was oakland
it was an overpriced death to america i
just mean look oakland's
always been a little radical that to me
is a level that we haven't
seen at least in 40 50 years and maybe
not ever
that you've now got an entire left i
mean elected democrats saying
america was never great this is a bad
country this is a racist country well
was there anything uplifting
at the dnc convention was there anything
uplifting was there any
really like being as objective as you
could possibly was there any moment
i mean i'm guessing biden tried to do
something on the uplifting side because
he can't
the thing is with biden he needs to fake
it for the confused dems
yeah so there must have been there must
have been a little something to that
right like
like this is still this is a great
country because he does because i think
that's what he believes
he said yeah he's going to restore the
country right i mean that's their
version
but that doesn't see that's what we said
before it doesn't work to say restore
the implication is oh that trump is the
one that screwed it up for the last
three years but their whole platform is
that the whole thing has been evil
for 200 years so what are you restoring
that's that sounds like make america
great again yes and the one thing that
biden said the one thing that was sort
of uplifting that biden said was
that uh he's going to bring the light
and not the darkness i thought you know
what's another word for bringer of light
is uh lucifer okay hold on no no
obviously it's a little
complicated but that was the line we're
gonna bring the light we're gonna bring
the light from the darkness but it
doesn't
that was all just kind of empty words he
didn't get into anything tangible i
would i would actually say the most
uplifting part of the convention was a
very dark part which was
they had this woman whose father died
from coronavirus and he liked
he liked trump and i guess he didn't
wear the mask the right way or something
and so he died very sad and
she went on and said donald trump killed
my dad and what she was really saying is
my dad is an idiot who believed donald
trump and he's what a fool he was he
should have listened to me because i
hate trump
and uh and anyway it's trump's fault for
some reason
when was the last dnc where they didn't
accuse the republican of killing
somebody
but also it just doesn't make sense i
mean right before i went off the grid
there were all the protests everywhere
and you had
thousands and thousands of maskless
people yeah protesting
they didn't die so i guess trump didn't
kill them but he did
it's like well you know in in many
places you were not allowed to
ask coronavirus patients if they had
participated in protests
you weren't allowed you could sound like
something the same society would do yeah
it was science scientific yeah yeah well
didn't wasn't there like a whole thing
where a bunch of scientists said that
racism is
is more of like a threat yes roma virus
or something like that like
over a thousand public health expert
scientists
said that white supremacy oh that's what
it was
white supremacy is a public health
threat that exacerbates coronavirus
so actually if you go and show up to one
of these ten thousand person rallies
you're actually helping stop this
problem you know that i know you know
this but there was a period uh about a
year ago where there was like a month
where like genuine
like white supremacists online whatever
whatever that is it's hard to tell if
they're just trolls or whatever right um
started showing up to some like turning
point events and college conservative
events and they should shut up
they show you know they showed up to
both of our yeah they showed up to ben's
events and they showed up to candace
owens events and a whole bunch of other
stuff
and you know what happened at all those
events oh they showed up to trump
junior's events
yeah yeah you know what happened all
those events we all shot them down we
all
argued with them uh some of us maybe
more effectively than others
but we but nobody acquiesced to the to
those bad
ideas no one gave an inch or gave
quarter to any of that
and yet the media the only time the
media covered it was when
uh trump jr sort of got a whole bunch of
people
screaming and mobbed and and the media i
watched the report on cnn they didn't
know what to do
because it was white supremacists angry
at trump jr now this doesn't make sense
isn't his base
supposed to be these people so they
showed it because they wanted to show
a mob with trump jr like that's good
like something bad's happening on the
right
but what they didn't really show was
that he was the one fighting against it
yeah and it's like that we need more of
that well did i
i guess i i didn't tell you about one of
joe biden's biggest new endorsements
have i not let me guess he got farrakhan
he got no
yeah oh it's better than that it's
better than farrakhan it's better give
me a hint
he is probably the most famous white
identitarian in the country
david duke uh oh richard spencer richard
spencer richard spencer and he said by
the
way
he said he said by the way for you
people who think i'm doing this
ironically
or what i'm not i think joe biden is
more competent than donald trump i think
the democrats are more competent than
the republicans
i am earnestly endorsing joe biden for
president but what's his play on the
white supremacist side of it
his well i i get it because because
identity politics is
is white supremacism it's black
supremacism it's it's supremacism
in and of itself but like i don't think
he probably probably didn't say that no
i don't think it's that i think
i think there's been a big uh
disappointment
among these kind of white supremacists
yeah people because
trump is not that yeah right trump
simply is not that
and the left can shout about it as much
as they want but it just hasn't come
true
and so the white identitarians are going
back to their roots
and rejoining the democratic party i
suppose or at least endorsing
joe biden i'm guessing that didn't get
much
i'm trying to check let me see new york
times or
probably made thedailywire.com yeah it
uh it has not
it has not shown up anywhere you know
the way that they dehumanize trump is so
the way that it's just any
they only throw this bad stuff they
never say anything nice so trump's
brother died
during the during the virus he was uh i
think his 70s or something like that
very sad you know yeah i didn't even
know he had a living brother i know he
he lost another bro he lost his older
brother fred
yeah this is his younger brother robert
they were very close yeah and it's very
sad
so do you know what trended when trump's
brother died
wish it was trump wrong trump wrong
trump trended
and the the headlines about it in
the washington post is uh was the the
headline was about how donald trump's
niece not
not his brother's daughter by the way
has a different brother how the niece
wrote this tell-all book about how
terrible trump is you say well what does
that niece have anything to do with the
brother who died
it reminded me of that's the treatment
that the president of the united states
gets
but when abu bakr al-baghdadi dies he's
a uh
gentlemanly scholar austere religious
scholar he is
yeah it's just so open right it's so out
in the open
and the big the big pitch from the
conventions the big pitch from the
protests
protests the big pitch from the riots
the big pitch from the people on the
coronavirus lockdowns what is it
this is the most important election in
our lifetimes and you always hear that
you say that's a bunch of bs
this time it is i think it is right
we're pretty much there this time
like yeah like we are hinging and the
entire world
yeah is now hinging on does freedom
matter
again this isn't like some tacit full
endorsement of everything that trump is
or does or anything like
it's just the tweets you're endorsing
every single i'm just endorsing every
single tweet and every single decision
he's ever made
yes but besides that yeah the choice now
we're deciding does
reality matter does do facts matter does
history matter
does anything that we thought mattered
that helped build something really great
here in america for 250 years
does any of it matter if you think that
it doesn't matter then you really should
the lefty be a progressive vote for
these guys destroy the whole damn thing
but it's just the people the very people
who are destroying the thing
if they only knew how much worse it
could be if they only knew
uh what what i mean and this i i say
this all the time and i say in my book
like
they should just they you don't have to
do a history lesson because i know they
think history was written by the evil
white supremacist
they should just talk to their parents
about what their grandparents lived
through yeah that's all you have to do
if you're an american
if you're an american and you think it's
so horrible right now yeah
talk to your parents about uh talk to
your grandparents if they're alive if
you're really lucky talk to your
great-grandparents
yeah maybe talk to your parents yeah and
is it better or worse and it's always
better for you it's
always better if you're an american in
2020 doesn't mean it's perfect
but every every story we've gone through
i mean we've gone through probably
dozens of stories yeah well the [ __ ]
bucket is just
obviously the most important one you can
rename it maybe you can write your own
response to the yeah the pb
it's all about the election right riots
are about the election the lockdowns are
about the election
the the elections about the election the
mail all this stuff
are there enough liberals you know kind
of
yeah open-minded liberals to be
persuaded and
will the events of the past month that
you have just missed out on that i have
filled you in on are they enough to
turn public opinion and get a democrat
to vote for that evil orange man that
mango mussolini well
i would say look at it slightly
different which is differently which is
if you let's just say we repeat exactly
what happened last time right so you
have
the people who voted for trump and the
people who voted for hillary i could see
a lot of people right now that are
seriously frustrated with the left yeah
kind of just holding their nose and
voting for trump just or or have fully
come around because i've seen plenty of
those people too oh yeah
um carl and borsenko who you probably
know from twitter from the knitting
group i've had on my show
like she's now a huge trump supporter
after being a lifelong lefty i think
there are a lot of people that are just
like
the left has gone completely bananas and
i either love
trump or i love what he represents or or
i'm gonna hold my nose and i'm gonna not
be polled and i'm gonna secretly vote
for him
try to imagine it the other way if you
voted for trump
yeah and suddenly you were like all
right it's now three and a half years
later what is it that trump did that
would get you
that would drive you to be like all
right i'm going to vote for the guys
that are kind of endorsing burning the
cities down yeah
like i i that jump i would love for
someone to explain it to me if they can
but i can't
you might say you know what i thought
trump was going to be more presidential
in his tweets or
richard spencer thought he'd be more of
a white supremacist so i guess all right
we got one oh thank you all right we got
one
which by the way you know when you said
that before remember when uh when
richard spencer said he was no longer
supporting trump which was months ago
yeah
he didn't say he was voting for biden
yet but but months ago he said he was no
longer supporting trump and they
announced that on the view
joy behar announced it on the view and
the clowns in the audience they're all
applauding and it's like you
ding bats do you realize you're
applauding a white supremacist just
because he doesn't support trump
to own the content yeah
okay so i can see i can see the leader
of the white supremacist going i've had
it with trump he's not good enough on
the white supremacy stuff he seems to
want black people to have jobs
i'm gonna vote for joe biden but i can't
where you really can see it the other
way like this i think that i think i'm
being as objective as possible
you could really be like you know what
trump's not perfect
basically likes america before
coronavirus the the economy was working
like we have a sense of what future
could look like with him yeah and i'm
gonna just
i don't love him but i'm gonna do it but
the other way seems i can't
really paint the it's short of the
disgruntled white supremacists this is
very interesting because
what it means you're actually giving me
a little glimmer of hope here yeah of
the way that people are going to move
so you came in here today a sweet
ignorant man
you've been away you know 30 days you
know what's funny i do feel a little
tightness in my chest right yes
not like heart attack but i do remember
i feel july tightness yes yes
that's the you we're all walking around
right back into it yeah quick two hours
yeah
but is it i knew i mean i was sort of
waiting i said oh dave he's having a
good day i'm going to ruin his
month but when you get to the end of
that yeah are you
are you pessimistic are you optimistic
or are you hopeful where do you stand
well i'm the same thing that i've always
described myself as which is i'm a world
weary optimist i'm not a wide-eyed
optimist like oh my god everything's
going to be great and like things are
going to be spectacular i'm a world
weary optimist i'm worried about the
world i
i worry about the world uh you know like
i mean the way david and i operate he's
very detail-oriented and
you know can plan a lot of things during
the day or if we have people
friends over for dinner what we're going
to do and all the things and it's all
great and wonderful
and i always say and he'll always say to
me what do you think about you know
should we put the glasses on this side
or
this that there and i'm always like well
iran could get the bomb you know
like i'm worried about these other these
other world things which is everything
that we're sort of talking about here
so i'm not i'm not an optimist in in
some like
imaginary way of being an optimist and
i'm not a pessimist because
you know i don't think you could do what
we do yeah and be a pessimist
because you'd kill yourself right you
really would because every day you'd
wake up you'd go oh man more bad stuff
you'd just be talking about it
negatively and it would kill you
i think that if
i mean i said it before but if enough of
us just try to deal
with this stuff honestly and just try
to slow down that wheel a little bit
yeah
and again just be a little bit better
than all the people who would love to
destroy us
i think that's that's the winning ticket
yeah that's the winning ticket that's
not be a republican or be
a democrat that's just like be a human
in a
be a functioning human in a messed up
time that's right be someone that just
thinks about your life and the world you
want to live in in somewhat of a serious
way it doesn't mean you're perfect
yeah obviously but like if you can do
that
it's sort of the orgasm box that you
were talking about before you know what
i mean like if you can get yourselves
back
if you can get your stuff in order yeah
then maybe
well yeah forget the orgasm box i'll be
serious for a moment yeah why did jordan
peterson want people to clean their room
the idea was don't clean the world
first and i think that's all the all the
social justice warriors and these
purple-haired
whack jobs that are screaming all day
long and it's like oh your life is so
obviously out of control and i have
sympathy for that and i've had times in
my life where obviously that was
we've all had that right we've all been
through those times
what did jordan say to people he said if
you clean your room first
take care of whatever your internal
struggles are which again are on
ongoing for all of us we all have times
where it's like really good for a while
and then
you might screw up and then you
backtrack or something like that but if
you do that first you might be able to
set the world right but everyone else is
focused on setting the world right all
these people who can't tie their shoes
are telling you what economic policy
should be and i'm more interested in in
helping people i get
some understanding of the world so that
maybe we can all do this together that's
right
so take care of yourself get yourself in
order then you can pick up your bucket
and your mop
and clean up get that bucket the [ __ ]
bucket man
i i'm gonna there's nobody marketing the
[ __ ] bucket that well that's what
right now that we have concluded you can
go run and at least make a buck on the
i'm gonna listen to this song
this you gotta go we'll play it we'll
play it after we cut the cameras dave
reuben thank you for joining us on the
reuben report here
thanks i am the guest hosting the reuben
i am so pleased it was a great honor
to come back and ruin dave's day i'm
michael knowles tune in next time
for the brand new graphics the brand new
sound the brand new
dave rubin on the reuben report and now
i'm retiring
you